Okay.
I want your help with something.
Um, this actually does not have anything to
do with the youtube issues that we're experiencing.
Every once in a while I just like to reflect
on the format of the show and think about
what changes we might be able to make to improve
the show.
Uh, based on changing, uh, demands, changing
interests from the audience and the different
platforms that we're on, sort of shifting
and reevaluating.
And very often we'll consider a change and
then we'll, we'll end up not doing anything
because the consensus ends up being keep doing
things the way that you're doing what you're
doing is working at least to some degree,
don't, uh, fix something that's not broken.
But we've in the past also sometimes made
good changes to the show, which from my perspective
have improved it and the show has continued
to grow.
So in a sense they weren't bad decisions,
at least not obviously so.
So remember that for every idea I'm about
to suggest to you, the constraint we have
is that we're doing a daily TV and radio show
that's an hour long.
So we're working within that timeframe of
an hour in order for the show to fit in to
the format of the nearly 200 TV and radio
affiliates that we have.
That's the show that gets chopped up into
pieces for youtube and are turned into our
daily audio podcast.
So don't freak out.
All of these are just ideas.
They're based on things I've heard from the
audience most frequently.
But none of these are changes we're necessarily
making.
These are just ideas that I will open the
door to hear from you about number one, a
lot of interview related ideas.
Some people don't like the interviews on the
show, they just want to hear commentary.
There's no rule that says we have to keep
doing interviews.
We've done something like 1500 interviews
on the show.
Uh, booking interviews is time intensive.
We could eliminate interviews altogether and
we could add stories.
So instead of doing six stories per show,
we could get rid of interviews and do eight
stories per show.
We could cut the interviews but not add any
stories, meaning we'll still do six stories,
but we can devote a little more time to each
of those six stories.
We could cut interviews and cut the number
of stories to only four, which would mean
the show would become, instead of sort of
like a summary of what happened in the last
24 hours or over the weekend, we would choose
four stories and cover each story for about
15 minutes.
But we would only be covering four things
per day that would say that would change the
nature of the show.
We could extend the interviews, make them
longer, but cut them to only a couple of times
a week.
So instead of for 13 to 15 minute interviews
per week, we would do just a couple, but they
could be a half hour long.
Instead of just 13 to 15 minutes.
We could do one interview per week and it
would be the entire show.
So imagine that maybe Wednesday the show instead
of being news and analysis is just an hour
interview with someone who warrants an hour
of discussion.
And then the rest of the week would be just
news stories.
Those are some ideas.
Live calls.
Now I know that the live calls are controversial.
We, we did a poll about live calls previously
and overwhelmingly the audience did want to
keep live calls even though lots of people
hate them and want them to go.
So live calls are not on the chopping block
right now, but we could change when and how
we do live calls.
So right now we do live calls on the Friday
show and then at the end of Monday through
Thursdays shows I'll play a voicemail from
the audience and react to it.
We could instead look at, for example, getting
rid of the voicemail segment, getting rid
of a half hour of live calls on Friday, and
just do two or three live calls at the end
of each show.
So we get rid of voicemails, we do like 10
minutes of live calls at the end of each show.
But there's no big block of 30 minutes of
calls on Friday.
That's a possibility.
Um, there are more logistics for that because
we'd need to open the phone lines every day
unless we recorded all the calls at once,
which would make some of them may be stale
and outdated.
It is more work on our end, but it's an idea
and as many of you know, I'm all about ideas.
I'm all about big ideas, small ideas, medium
ideas, stale ones, new ones, whatever.
I'm throwing them out to you.
So here is how I want to hear from you about
this.
Only by email.
There's a reason why it's too easy to just
put up a poll on Twitter or on our website
or on Youtube and let people vote and just
click something without really thinking about
it.
And the thing is that most people often don't
want anything changed.
But if they're given a list of options, they'll
just pick something and we get sort of cloudy
data.
If you actually care enough to want something
changed on the show, whether it's from the
options I mentioned or something different
altogether, email me through the contact form@davidpacman.com
okay.
David pakman.com click on contact.
Fill out that form and tell me which of these
ideas you like.
If any, tell me if you want everything to
stay as it is.
Tell me if there's a change that you would
like that I have not mentioned.
Okay.
All of these ideas and others I'm willing
to consider and the advantage of having to
email me instead of just clicking a poll is
that if you, number one, have an idea I didn't
mention, we can also include it and consider
it.
I want those as well.
Uh, but if you want nothing changed.
That's also useful to hear because if 80%
of the audience writes in and says, David,
don't change anything, that's important for
us to hear.
The whole point here is the show is for you.
I want the show to be what people want in
terms of the format.
Obviously I'm going to still pick the guests.
I'm going to still cover the stories I want
to cover, but as far as the format goes, let
me know what you think.
I'll give it like a week or so and then I
will come to you with the results and uh,
whatever decisions we make about the format
of the show,